there are some fans and viewers who are
saying i'm not watching this season
because of kelly what's your message to
them maybe you could just say follow
through
season 15 your third on the show
how is the gina we're seeing this time
around different than the geno we met
three years ago well okay first of all
she is 40 pounds heavier
and has really bad hair
but she's really happy so it's okay it's
all good
let's talk about the hair because the
hair is a whole thing it's it's a meme
every week it's gonna be a meme how do
you feel about
people making fun of it i'm okay with it
because like i'm not blind
like i see what's going on there and
like the bottom line is
i just made this bad decision to
just start down this road with like the
extension and then the platinum
destroyed my actual hair
and then i got it back to the right
color but then like i had no hair left
so then i had to have the extension so
but then what you're seeing is like this
extension and then like the top
that's my actual like frizzle frazzled
dead hair so i get it
all of it i'm not proud of it
but you know what i mean it is what it
is what am i gonna
do no it's entertainment for people i
did my own hair and makeup today and i'm
very great
so you look great we're we're coming
back around
it's like what it's old is new again
and i lost weight i mean i was like bit
like i was just like
i just am who i am relationship weight
is totally a thing
you and travis you are have you hit the
year mark yet
yeah no we're past the year we've been
it was uh august 15th so we're like a
year in three months i'm really happy
i think it's the happiest they've ever
been in a relationship
for sure what's the biggest difference
between your marriage
and then this relationship the one thing
you didn't know you needed or didn't
have when you were in that marriage
i just think that um matt and i didn't
have like a
like a deep foundation a connection up
that partnership i just think it's so
confusing when you're young
and everybody else is getting married
and you you know you love them
and you you know but now i know what
it's what it is to be
in love so and it's one of those things
you can't really describe it until you
have it
yeah and then once you can't really
describe i still can't describe it but i
know i have it
i think the fans were very surprised i
was very surprised the trailer comes out
matt appears on this season for the
first time
how why explain this to me okay well
the reason that matt never filmed was
and i know people
could believe this or not but it was
truth was because his employer
would not allow him to so and then
unfortunately in this is
you know it has been really hard for
everyone but as a result of everything
that happened last year
how much can you tell us about what
allegedly happened the night of
june 22nd he just was like a different
person
it was risky you know and i ran out of
the house and
rang my neighbor's doorbell i was being
on the door and he's
dragging me back in the house oh my god
then the cops came
they arrested him he could face possibly
seven years in jail
matt was uh let go from his job
so he now had free will and choice
and um you know i just like i
i really appreciate that he did do it
and i thought that it would be
good for people to see that you know we
can go through such traumatic
experiences and come together for our
children and we really
do so and you really do co-parent well
and he's a good dad
when everything went down though you did
get a restraining order against him
and i thought that that was still an
effect so how does that work with him
coming around
well okay so the thing about a
restraining order is in order for him
to actually get actively you know in
trouble for something like that i would
have to
support it in and we're allowed as part
of the restraining order actually we're
allowed
we're allowed to be by each other but
only for
like when it comes to the children you
know what i mean and i'm not like going
to like hang out with that
so we're really we're only around each
other if it's
child related well that's good to hear
that even through
all through everything that happened the
kids are still
number one and that hasn't gotten lost
yeah and it never will all right let's
pivot to the women
you're an emily's margarita scene
margarita ketchup was so much fun
oh my god we're like the new tres amigos
those idiots
what is that idiot idiots
you guys are back to being where you
were when you first joined the show
together right
i think i honestly feel like even better
i actually watched that scene twice and
i was laughing
you know so i can appreciate and
understand how other people
i i think that people really liked that
i think people did i think everyone but
bronwyn maybe liked that moment
yes yes yes and sean i'm sure bronwyn
hey there i heard you're taking shots at
me i got this
why you know why you said some really
things and i found out about it and
they're not cool
what are they maybe all that bleach went
to your brain
but i'm not gonna say this over the
phone let's get into the bronwyn sean of
it all
okay one do you regret the margarita
induced phone calls
to bronwyn no ron renew about those text
messages
a long time ago she's been sitting on it
and then
the cameras go up and then i
i knew she was saying things about me
because i felt like i was
doing her solid by not bringing it up
and then i was kind of like
ambushed with it you know so and she had
so much so many opportunities just to
call me and talk to you directly about
it
and it wouldn't have been point out of
proportion because i would have said
yeah you know what i have different
boundaries it made me a little
uncomfortable
she's going around saying the whole year
saying we have three sons i have a sex
apartment
rolling around on the floor with tamra
but then i'm crazy for thinking that
i might have a i might have a shot she
said the only requirement is you have to
be hot so okay
i understand i'm not hot enough to do
this video this is messed up i've been
nothing but nice to you
and every time i'm nice to you throw it
back in my face it was so
weird to me because she's like trying to
accuse me of like
me being so wasted that i couldn't even
get an uber
so i couldn't understand and i'm like
meanwhile like you were passed out and
like that is honestly how
most of the nights that we would film
would end with her and then
we would be you know it you have to go
to them the next thing and now we're all
in a group and we're talking about all
the things that happen at this party or
whatever
and she wouldn't she had no idea what
was ever going on who was
frustrating as a cast
to like work with her you know i think
she was
uh projecting it seems like it's gonna
be a weird
season i mean pandemic aside everything
that happened in the world aside but a
weird season with everyone and bronwyn
she has made it clear she's not talking
to anybody
um what's what's the deal there
why are why is why the disconnect with
broadway
i don't know i think the the bottom line
is i think that
she is coming to terms with this
alcoholism
and now she is um
looking within and coming out um and
letting everybody know that she's gay
and i think these are two
extremely big issues that she's dealing
with so
i honestly i don't know why but
if that's what she needs then you know
i'm not i'm not trying to make things
worse for her and her family because i
i do think that they're going through a
tremendous time right now you know and
i i think probably her behavior has been
erratic this year
and i think it probably will continue to
be erratic
bronwyn told us that the
sloppy chihuahua drink throwing moment
is her rock bottom i leave the party i
walk home since we're so close
i say get the f out of my house i'm
spiraling i was spiraling
fast and uh if the crew hadn't have been
here
i know without a doubt i would have had
a drink that day i know that
oh my god i feel terrible about
her i don't want to be that mirror i
didn't know if
she had a problem you know so i think
that that makes me feel actually i do i
feel bad but i mean i guess it's good
but like
like i don't want to be like somebody's
rock bottom story
where do things go after the sloppy
chihuahua drink throw moment because
both shannon and emily told me that
bronwyn's authenticity is in question
like
all season long from the group
yeah i think now for the first time
she's sober and she's trying to have to
figure out who she is
and i and i i i don't think that she's
quite there you don't just you know say
i'm sober and i'm an alcoholic and then
whatever it is eight months later or
whatever sobriety have it all figured
out i think it's extremely commendable
that she has
admitted and as saying she has this
problem
but i think um maybe some of the other
women is hard for them to understand
because when you look at like what she's
presenting on social media it looks like
she's fast tracked right through
all the other stuff you're right people
uneasy
bronwyn to this day is saying that
shannon made these comments about your
new house can you make fun of her
like a condo and say oh my god how does
she live in 1600 square feet oh i did do
that
that's what she's pissed about oh well
yeah but i'm not the only one doing that
did we ever get to the bottom
of whether shannon made fun of your
house
i mean she's never ever i mean i'll tell
you i'll tell you honestly
i don't think she'll ever admit it she
probably did but um
the bottom line is though with the
broadway situation she did this and
you're like
did you say this thing no
there's no accountability no
responsibility her excuse for why it's
okay
is because she's not the only one who
did it and to me
that's like a a toddler response you
know that's like a
a it's very immature to me it's very
wanting to pass a book well let's talk
about someone else whose mouth gets them
in a lot of trouble
kelly died
the audience has has really seemed to
take a stand on
how they feel about kelly with
everything that's happened between the
pandemic
black lives matter where do you stand
with kelly
it's hard because
she's just wow god she just can't have
her own way
you know and it's like i i don't know i
don't agree with any of it
i don't like any of it you know but
i don't i don't the thing about kelly is
i
want to believe that she doesn't mean a
lot of the stupid
things that she says but she says that
you know i wish i i don't know like i
don't know if she
you know regrets or doesn't regret
if she does things that make it harder
and harder
to you know be supportive of her
it's just you know and i and it's just
it's hard it's just
like every day too something is it
something you guys talk about either
with kelly
or as a group i know that emily
keeps down her you know you gotta keep
your mouth shut like
but um she doesn't and you know that's
kelly she's just never gonna do that but
i do think that
she needs to the thing is like there's a
difference between saying what's on your
mind and being insensitive
and i think that she needs to understand
that hopefully
though this is a learning experience for
her you know i really i i do hope that
yeah i i think we all hope that there
are some fans and viewers who are saying
i'm not watching this season
because of kelly what's your message to
them i do think that if somebody really
has been offended and
feels like they've been victimized by
something that she said i understand if
they want to take a stand and they don't
want to watch like i
i get that i but there are five other
women here
and there is a lot of like very
important
things happening to a lot of us and um
maybe you could just start following her
first part
i i'll take it all right anything else
you want to say
about what we're going to see this
season it's a different kind of season
but
also yeah there is going to be a lot of
fun you guys
elizabeth is
is elizabeth and yeah hurricane
is a bruin so i think like honestly
i'm so interested to see even how
they pull it all together for her but
she is a very interesting person and i
think
the fans will appreciate that and um
i think it's interesting to see there's
a lot of uh
friendships that
change and and
and things that happen there's just a
lot there's a lot of things that happen
in such a small amount of time like you
have like
the fact that we were only filming for
like i think a little over a month
and we still have as many episodes as we
have
i'm like my god this would if this
season if not for colbit it would have
been 45 episodes
[Music]